CALL THE ROLL STATUS ONE HAND.
PAN HERE STONE STONE HERE
GONZALEZ INSULTS HERE GROW
FURTADO LEYVA. LEYVA HERE
MITCHELL MONNING HERE MONNING
HERE RUBIO. HEY WE HAVE A
QUORUM HERE AUTHORS HERE
SO WELCOME SO I COME UP TO US
SO PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE
TWENTY NINE TEN SEE WE ARE
HEARING WHEN BILL TODAY AND
THAT'S EIGHTY NINE TWENTY BY
SOME EVER TOUCHING NORRIS AND
SUBJECT TO BE USED RECOVERY
TREATMENT PROVIDERS I WANT TO
REMIND PEOPLE OF THE RULES OF
THE COMMITTEE WHICH ARE WILL
TAKE UP TO SIX MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY DOT THESE ALL THE
TIME. AND FAVOR VAULT AND TAKE
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY SIX
MINUTES AND THEN AN OFF COURSE
AFTER EACH OF THE BUT WELL
AFTER THE PRODUCTIVITY TWOS AND.
CONSTITUTES AS WELL. OKAY
WELCOME THANK YOU. I'M HERE I'M
HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY. NINE TWENTY
ODD THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE ALL
OUTPATIENT SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT PROGRAMS. TO BE
LICENSED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
PROTECT PATIENTS WHO ARE IN
RECOVERY. FOR SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
THIS POLLS LANGUAGE FROM
SENATOR HELL'S SB THREE TWENTY
FIVE WHICH WAS PREVIOUSLY
HEARD. IN THIS COMMITTEE AND
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY AND IF.
YOU'VE GOT TO AS SUPPORTERS
HERE. TO TESTIFY. I THANK YOU
WITNESSES SUPPORT. ROBERT
HARRIS ON BEHALF OF THE ONE OF
THE CO SPONSORED BILL
CALIFORNIA'S LADY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE THIS IS A FINELY AT
THE BEST STEP WE CAN DO TO
CONTROL A- BED SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT OF THE BEEN GIVEN THE
PRODUCE HAPPENING IN ORANGE
COUNTY SO. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. DAVID IS THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU FOR PREVIOUSLY VOTING FOR
TO HELP YOU DO SO AGAIN TODAY.
THANK YOU I WHAT THIS IS A
SUPPORT. BACK BACK IN FRONT OF
QUE SAYING NONE BUT WHAT IS THE
SUPPORT OKAY ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I'D SAY NINE
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ALL RIGHTS BEEN MOVED
BY CENTER STILL. THE NO
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AIDS THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AS
THOUGH CERTAINLY AND IS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF IT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU AND I'D
JUST LIKE TO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS
BILL I TOOK TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN
THE SESSION ON BEATING THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD AND
THAT APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. OKAY
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
IS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER STONE
CIRCLE PLEASE CALL. YEAH I
DON'T YEAH THERE WAS NO. THAT'S
NOT SO WITH THAT SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND I PAN
AYE STONE STONE AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROW HER TADO LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE MITCHELL. MONNING
MONNING AYE RUBIO RUBIO AYE.
SIX PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AGAIN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE HER
TADO HER TITLE I. MITCHELL.
SEVEN OKAY THE BILL'S CURRENTLY
SEVEN ZERO OKAY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AGAINST AFTER MEMBERS.
GROWTH MITCHELL. MITCHELL FIVE
MITCHELL I. OKAY SO THE BILL IS
THAN AL TWO EIGHT ZERO THANK
YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT TO SHARE
DROUGHT TAKING THE TIME QUE
WITH THAT THIS CONCLUDES THE
AGENDA OF THE. SENATE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH THIS HEARING IS NOW
ADJOURNED